wie geil ist das denn bitte ich bin ja
richtig gut oder wahrscheinlich ist
dieses spiel einfach nicht schwer
denk sind hallo ich meine lieben freund
und herzlich willkommen zu einem
weiteren oder weniger ich habe mir
gedacht ich spiele heute mal das spiel
crysis oder cross ihr oder kann hier auf
pause drücken damit ihr mal okay so
heißt höchste 21 was passiert jetzt
irgendwas über das was du sagen dass
weitergehe jedenfalls kann ich hier in
dem ich da so drüber wisse einfach
dieses hühnchen hier so dran bewegen und
ich hüpfe jetzt mal hier hoch jüngst
falls ihr euch eventuell fragen sollte
was meine stimme angeht da als ich so
ein bisschen heiser bin und alles
mögliche waren gestern auf der krankheit
modell konzert und das war nie sehr
stark mitgenommen ich muss jetzt
irgendwie bei dieser straße sind nämlich
irgendwie gab es nicht mal so ein spiel
mit zum vorjahr war das knappe hab ich
mal so ein spiel mit so einem frosch
irgendwie wo man mit seiner frau darüber
hüpfen musste ich will unbedingt diese
münze haben jetzt muss ich das ja schon
wie weihnachten hier 100 ich muss noch
herausfinden was wollen wir diesen kurs
irgendwie machen kann nach preis gewinne
ich kann den preis gewinnen
ach guck mal schöne geschenke maschine
okay jetzt solche gekauft und jetzt
bekomme ich einen preis
etwas runter ich habe einen hund balu
ihr seid ja ein puzzle schwanz jeder
denken einfach bestimmt dass mir geraten
durchgezogen habe mir meine augen sind
so roth ich habe einfach fünf stunden
geschlafen oder sowas eigentlich noch
relativ vieles und ich muss auch gleich
eine halbe stunde aber egal wir spielen
weiter das spiel aber crossroad als ob
ich kann jetzt den steuern
ich bin der who
grund ist auch schon viel besser nicht
ein spieler ich merke dass hier jetzt
kommt er sogar anzug lag also ich find
das spiel ist echt mit sehr sehr sehr
sehr viel liebe zum detail gemacht ich
liebe ja solche spiel sehr sehr cool und
ich hab jetzt ist jetzt level geschafft
oder auch kummer ich muss hier über
diese teile darüber ab ob ich liebe
dieses spiel alte das ist ja richtig
cool
ok kommen kleiner hund jetzt hier hier
hier ja wahrscheinlich kommt direkt von
lkw ok ich muss jetzt irgendwie diesen
kleinen bruder
ich muss mir irgendwie und zack und blub
blub blub blutsbruder und über die
gleise darüber schnell so und jetzt
kommt der zug und jetzt kann ich hier
und jetzt
was ist das ist schon krass
das ist schon sehr sehr geil ich habe ja
gesagt wenn ich ein spiel entwickeln
würde wird es von von anfang bis ende
immer leichter werden und ich glaube so
ein spiel wird hier einfach nicht
verkaufen fällt mir so hier bin ich
erstmal safe auf diesem ding und jetzt
zeigt die münze holt kann ich eigentlich
nicht ich habe versucht noch weiter nach
rechts zu gehen das ist das level nach
rechts und in eine andere richtung immer
weiter erweitert aber eine egal ist das
denn bitte ich bin ja richtig gut oder
wahrscheinlich ist dieses spiel einfach
nicht schwer
denkst du jetzt mal nur zum verständnis
der hat mich jetzt geholt weil ich
zurück gesprungen bin ich blickte fast
ganz teilen auf twitter nicht nur noch
mal ganz gut zum verständnis er hat mich
geschnappt weil ich rückwärts gesprungen
bin
ich bin jetzt noch mal rückwärts
gesprungen ist nichts passiert oder
warte ich mal kurz hier auf die straße
so und jetzt springe ich wieder zurück
kommt auch keiner was ist was dann los
wie wohl ich dann vom makler geholt
verstehe ich gar nicht jetzt habe ich
einen teppich na gut
warum ich könnte mir jetzt ein geschenk
bitte das einfach noch ein hund drin und
irgendwie sowas 800 kein hersteller in
den juni dann bitte was der typ hat gar
keine motivation dieser kiwi kann der
kunde aber naja probieren was man mit
diesem mann jetzt mein speed run hier
ganz ganz schnell einfach durch ich muss
wieder an einem stück kommentieren damit
das ganze natürlich wieder läuft ihr
kennt das freundin nicht am stück
kommentieren
dann ist das ganze richtig gut und
regellos kiwi ag zug fuhr aber das knapp
alter mann schon wieder ein zug geht bin
ich jede auf und jetzt nicht mehr die
mühe zu alter wie viele züge kommen denn
hier ich wünschte es wäre deutschland
also in deutschland hätten die züge
fahren wieder zehn minuten verspätung
und würden einfach mit seiner
schrittgeschwindigkeit das spiel in
deutschland alter hier werden nur raser
auf der autobahn das heißt die ganzen
autos wären einfach extrem schnell und
die ganze züge wenn einfach extrem
langsam an gegen solche regionalverkehr
als symbol das nein ich dachte kommt
deutsche zu bekomme ich dafür irgendwas
dass ich mir das jetzt ihr angeguckt hat
es verdient du spiele ich denke ich mit
in app käufen also ich denke man kann
sich da echt irgendwie alter guckt euch
dieses denkmal an der effekt der guckt
einfach offen wenn ich
guck mal ich hab mich mal gefragt was
oben links mit der zahl ist wenig zur
seite für erhöhte sich nie aber immer
wenn ich nach vorne rückt für das ist
quasi wie viele strecken schon überquert
haben da war ja gerade auch voll gut das
wasser als einfach so pixel hatte
gewesen
wahrscheinlich muss ich das video sogar
gleichen der uni schneiden alter das
wird ja noch das krasseste ich muss in
25 minuten der uni sein und für sein
video was sich so immer so ein bisschen
mehr bearbeitet also das ist ja auch
noch nicht viel gearbeitet ich weiß da
gibt es leute die machen das natürlich
viel krasser aber da sitze ich dann
schon halt immer so eine stunde dran und
ich denke ich muss gleich das ganze in
der uni bearbeiten und dann sitze ich
habe mit meinem laptop sowie obst ich
bearbeite video hier übrigens gestern
auf diesem klang karussell konzert auf
dem ich war da war so ein typ der hat
mich halt angesprochen so jung bruder
alter und normalerweise trifft mal so
beim feiern nie irgendwelche leute die
youtube dich kennen und so weil das wenn
die da wahrscheinlich denn hin
normalerweise trifft beim feiern halt
nie so leute weil die halt alle meistens
so 18 und älter sind und die leute die
ihr dasein schaut ich weiß nicht wie alt
seite schreibt damit in die kommentare
wie alt ihr seid das wird mich halt echt
mal das würde mich echt extrem
interessieren weil im google analytics
steht immer das alle von euch zwischen
13 und 16 sind so nett war und er war so
19 oder so eine serie hier du bist du da
von youtube ich so celik weil die
gleiche musik ich liebe leute die die
gleiche musik feiern einfach und kranke
aus selm hat extrem gute musik finde ich
es gibt kein gut oder schlecht und jetzt
dass sie wieder aus und sondern musik da
kann man halt so anja manchmal die
kleinen sich so
denn irgendwie nicht so gut in dem spiel
und so und alle hassen mich dafür dass
ich so
dann kam erhält so anja ich habe auch
ein kanal ich mache auch gleich schafft
letztlich 130 tausend abonnenten
da dachte ich mir schon so bruder läuft
bei dir das war echt war echt ganz ganz
ganz schlecht dass ich dann einfach mal
so einen beim feiern getroffen was ist
wenn ich gegen so ein baum hiergegen hat
für das war echt eine ganz interessante
begegnung das hatte ich auch noch nicht
ich hatte beim feiern zwar einmal nach
dem feiern im subway das ist nicht wahr
schon wieder werbung für die siedler
oder was ist das ich kann mich echt
nicht angucken ich will gar nicht in der
uni guckt mich mal an ich bin ich sehr
so fertig aus obwohl ich gar nicht gar
nicht so lange weshalb hier weg oder
gameplay sind und ich lade euch hiermit
mein problem ich egal dafür bekommt
jetzt nochmal einmal ihr eben schnellen
speed run wo ich das jetzt mal eben hier
einfach durch spieler das spiel so
laufen wir hier eben rüber laufen weil
hier zwischen er natürlich
hier auch die straße hier auf die
strategie auf die reise war ganz schön
wenn man dann auf diesen kleinen
blättchen hier ist das ist immer ganz
kittel jetzt hier über ihr wieder auf
das komische blättchen drauf dann hier
auf den steh ich hier auf den stetig auf
den steg jubla blood axis taxifahrer und
schnell rüber und ich brauchen stetig
besteht darin steht dass der steg und
jetzt ein stück und hier und hier und
blauen block und blieb hier über und
zack und bands und woods um fans und
vips und wird bald zum friseur
viele meinen
hier wieder rüber und hier drop jahr
wahrscheinlich ist sie so ein riesen
gleise geben hier noch den kölnern staat
wollen dass ich mir gleich wieder ein
tolles neues türchen kaufen kann so
jetzt hier über er wir sind schon mal 83
wenn ich bei 100 bin ist das mein
letzter dran gewesen weil ich jetzt auch
echt auch mal langsam in die uni muss
dass man sie ehrlich gesagt sagen aber
das werde ich jetzt sowohl ich irgendwie
hinkriegen oder hat man hier über hier
jetzt hier drauf hier drauf hier drauf
da ist man genau auf meinem hobby nicht
gestorben
vollidiot gar noch mal eben schnell ein
geschenk an staat und das sind wie viele
accounts 75 er das geschenk kann ich
erst in 30 minuten
ich kann doch ein geschenk holen das
muss eben was cool ist irgendwie am
besten als rechtshänder ananas oder
irgend so ein williger aus minecraft
oder irgendwie sowas kommt es ist ein
lila frau
okay das ist ein recht auch diese ganzen
größe pro portion vor als es gäbe so
riesige fläche so groß wie so ein führer
dieser scheiß adler ja gut freuen ich
würde auf jeden fall sagen das ganze war
es dann mit crossroad ich habe jetzt
noch 20 minuten um das ganze zu
bearbeiten tut mir leid falls ich nicht
so viel gearbeitet habe habe ich muss
jetzt in die uni und dann wenn es euch
gefallen hat zeigt man dann bewerten
schreibt mir andere spiele die ich auf
meinem ipad hier spielen soll
schreibt mir dass ihm die kommentaren in
dem man nicht einmal die datei